I hope you noticed like the the number
work of this the arithmetic not that
complicated
number one is a cute you looked at last
time into our last exercise and you see
this in previous years the mysticism end
is really when thank you is really when
you take these numbers and say well okay
what conclusion kind of drama and one
will have a discussion let's focus on
others first so for Part B you look at
the equation that they give you right
I'm just going to write that first D
equals waiting on y plus 12 okay now
first order of business is because
you've got a new formula right I'm gonna
take these printables that I had before
and I'm gonna get rid of them because
they may or may not have anything to do
with the way this new guide is music
wait to the store okay so I have a wine
and have name where does the a come from
that's the easy part first mercifully it
is actually the same thing that has
stood for before so we've got lucky on
that one but what I didn't appear in the
previous question or what is why it's a
child aging years you see how much of a
payoff it was that we paid careful
attention to who lives last so this is
in fact not why this is actually well
it's it's much to me to be one okay so
in order to get this Y is going to be
equal to now pretty months are there in
the year twelve which is a bit of a pain
right I have to take sixteen and rather
than divide by 10 which is what I
usually do by decimal point so on I have
to divide by 12 and occasionally no he
actually used to have ten months notice
that like what's the last month the year
December see Dec like decagon or
anything this at the neck is ten times
they wonder why we have 12 months
actually yes
very good yet so Julia City done it to
get to why from it does the cigs ID so
we get August from and because they were
Emperor's they're like inference have to
have 31 days in the month we can't be
like a sub state and month we have that
study was that's why pull February gets
shafted and only usually has to innate
accepted this okay so that's what I
would you find my 12 okay
so pay careful attention when you put
these in when you mom what you're
evaluating them is I'm just gonna put
the actual just straight substitution
before I get to my calculate up this one
here is 16 over 12 plus 12
I'm sorry that's 20 and on the
denominator I had that 16 over times
I've 68 12 again plus 12 I was doing the
denominator so this is fine I can put
this into my calculator if I want make a
royal best I can we think back to some
of the work we do with fractions before
to make this a bit time is everything we
can do 16 over 12 like I can simplify
that surely a consumer right what would
you write instead okay you can I to go
1.33 333 or if you want to be exact
before that's exactly okay now once you
go she don't put you later you're going
to get if you pop it Ella improperly and
be careful with your brackets and your
fraction line etc you should get exactly
to yeah
on the money okay now if you have a good
pot see pot see thankfully is pretty
much as straightforward as a so I'm just
gonna go ahead and give you the on-site
if final recall I think it rounds off to
two point three like to go to or
something or other
yeah it comes up to two point three okay
all right we have our answers now but
what do we do with them because they're
all different
did anyone have an on side that they
came up with one offer up their reason
why any takers
okay so a reasonably they don't I had a
conversation with some you
is to look at these let's see one two
three numbers and say well at least
they're all on the right ballpark that's
a good thing okay they're pretty close
to each other so I get some kind of
average them out I'll take the mean okay
that's a great way to go what is the
mean two point one is it like is it is
it anything off two point one I guess
you'd round it off yeah which makes
sense because this is in the middle of
those two I'd give a big tick on that
now the reasoning why there's a couple
of things to it I guess number one
they're all in the same ballpark that's
the best thing number two remember I
showed you just now I froze it took up
like that doesn't matter I showed you
what the streets look like before right
there are more decimal places but Kimmy
you can't do anything with them because
you can't measure them so you don't need
to worry about those I probably one more
reason on there which is that when you
look at all of these numbers like
they're all based off pretty similar
numbers and one of these that they
haven't told you is that that's about
right that's about an average weight for
a child of this age okay now suppose you
have a baby who is maybe baby's
premature really really tiny so they're
old but maybe their weight is like off
the tongue something like that that's
way lower than it ought to be if I
change the situation your numbers are
all going to be different right well I
take that back actually one of the
numbers will not be different which
numbers going to stay the same the first
two don't care about the mass today did
you notice that it all about age but
you're gonna know okay actually age is
not everything mass this one's like
off-the-charts oh that's why that third
number I expect you'd be significantly
lower and you'd probably say okay rather
just average them out
does that make sense
don't just finally use the numbers you
have to think about what they mean and
therefore want you to
as a result